the damage is overwhelming for the
people returning are just emerging after
48 Hours under Israeli assault a chance
to assess what has been lost what can be
rebuilt
they don't know what they're doing what
do they achieve they just destroyed the
infrastructure in the camp so what
Sharif al-arsal showed us where the
Israelis had set up a sniper position in
his home they spent bullets littering
the floor
they tied my hands and broke me to the
window I don't know what they wanted but
he pointed his gun from behind me they
gained entry by pushing through the wall
from the house next door all they heard
was a mighty crash
his neighbor zahira Carini lost her
husband on Sunday just hours before the
assault began she hasn't had the time or
the chance to bury him
we were all sitting here the shelling
and shooting was raging there were seven
or eight of us the soldiers blasted
through from a neighbor's house and they
took us one by one to the room next door
her grandson Islam is just one month old
he'll be told of what happened here as
he gets older but for now his mother
Irene wants him as close as much as
possible
for some just getting back into their
home was a challenge
we don't care about homes the most
important thing is the safety of the
people
reconstruction has started they're
trying to reconnect the electricity
Supply here to this part of the camp
it's a small step but at the moment a
small step is at least a step forward
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Janine refugee
camp in the occupied West Bank
and Alan is joining us live from Janine
now where he has spent all of Wednesday
morning and funerals are now taking
place there for those who've been killed
Alan
that's right the thousands of people
have turned out for the funerals that
we've seen just in the last couple of
hours a long procession through the
streets of Janine towards at the
cemetery we're now in sharif's how you
see it featured in the report we want to
give you an idea of what he went through
first of all he was brought here with
his hands tied and was told to stand
here he says then that a soldier put the
gun underneath his arms and told him
just to stand there as he used this as a
sniper's position and you can still see
the spent cartridges
on the floor now if we walk through to
another part of the house you will see
where we've got to be very careful
negotiating this because there's a lot
of bricks and blocks first of all I want
to show you where another sniper's
position was set up how the soldiers not
throw a hole in the wall and you can see
the view out of there they've got a view
down to the camp so of course the
question then becomes how did the
soldiers manage to get into this house
and it becomes very clear when you turn
around here
they came through the neighbors and
before that the neighbors before that so
they pushed their way through this house
through the wall
and I'm now standing in next door
neighbor's house and that is how they
made their way through a lot of the
streets here in Janine they've got the
cover so people can't see them out in
the open but they make sure that they're
protected by not being in an area
where they can be spotted by snipers so
that is the sort of thing that people
have been going through over the last 14
hours and Alan
what you were describing is very
important for us to remember that none
of this is allowed under international
law using
Sheltering behind a civilian breaking
into people's homes and we've heard from
the UN Human Rights Chief who has
described the the sort of things that
exactly that you're talking about that
happened in the Janine refugee camp and
Howard does not square up with
international law
well do you know I've been speaking to a
couple of young men gunmen they're with
one of the Armed groups here in Janine
camp and they have been fighting over
the last 48 hours for very obvious
reasons they didn't want to go on camera
but they told us that the reason they
took up arms which is a question asked
them why do you feel the need to fight
they feel they've been sold out they
feel they have been ignored and left
alone they feel that no one is listening
to them that they have a plight here
that no one really cares about and they
only see the answer to that through what
they describe as armed resistance which
is why they took up guns I asked them
how bad things were over the last 48
hours and they said in the fighting they
actually said it wasn't too bad the
worst part were the missiles coming in
because they knew they were hitting
perhaps Fighters but also ordinary
civilians but that doesn't make them
want to stop doing what they're going to
do and they continued on their way up
the street towards one of the funerals
carrying their weapons and saying that
if Benjamin Netanyahu says what it's
true what he says that this is just the
start of operations in Janine they said
they will be here
Alan thank you very much for that that
is Alan Fisher bringing us the picture
um of the aftermath from Janine